hey this so this next story is not the
biggest story but i
i do like something that nancy pelosi is
doing because it's fighting donald trump
with his own tactics
in a way that's not immoral now i've
pointed out many times before
we are trying to fight the immorality of
the right we are trying to fight the
destructive impulses of the right
we don't want to fight those destructive
immoral
impulses by being destructive and
immoral
ourselves so on a lot of policy-based
things i've made it very clear
we should not stoop to their level we we
don't the country doesn't benefit in the
long run
from the left becoming just as
destructive and immoral as the right
merely to justify replacing the right
however there are some optics elements
where i actually think it's okay to
adopt some of the strategies of trump
and one of these is nancy pelosi
starting to refer to the coronavirus as
the trump virus
now a few weeks ago i jokingly uh
tweeted we should really call it trump
cov20 and some people liked it some
people didn't
but really the idea is we have to brand
trump with the failure we have to brand
the failure with donald trump's name
and nancy pelosi is doing it this
doesn't mean nancy pelosi is a
progressive
this doesn't mean anything other than
nancy pelosi
is using one of trump's more innocuous
techniques
against trump and i know there are
people who are going to flippantly say
okay nancy
you know trump virus is clever but what
about getting people relief money
i agree right i'm not saying that this
is a replacement or an excuse
for anything but i do think that
fighting trump's
you know kung flu stuff uh with some of
his own medicine is interesting
nonetheless so here's nancy pelosi on
cnn
it is a pandemic that has gotten worse
before it will get better
because of his inaction and in fact
clearly
it is the trump virus
well what do you mean when you say the
trump virus the type virus if they if he
had
said months ago let's wear a mask let's
not
let socially distance instead of having
rallies and political whatever they were
then more people would have followed his
lead
as the president of the united states
instead of being a bad example making
it like a manhood thing not to wear a
mask so any event
was weird because a briefing on the
coronavirus should be about science
and that is something the president has
ignored it should be about governance
and now he's finally embracing saying
okay it's okay to wear
a mask so i think a good deal of what we
have suffered
is clearly the trump virus now i know
that even within our audience there's a
split
on this type of thing what's the point
of these superficial things when nancy
pelosi has been part of
the failure to get substantive financial
relief to all americans people are
writing to me
you know this is crumbs when we need a
main course trump virus ooh okay
what about money for people who need it
i agree with you i agree with you but to
restate
this is not a replacement or an
alternative to anything that should
have been done and should be done and
could be done failures remain
failures whether they're the democratic
party or trump or the republican party
or whoever
but the attempt to brand trump
with the excess destruction of this
pandemic
is not stupid it's the number one issue
right now for voters in the 2020
election
more people than necessary have died
because of this administration's
mishandling of the coronavirus so if
it's the most
important issue to voters and according
to a recent poll it is and
trump has failed on it and it's one of
the biggest drags
on donald trump's approval and we all
understand
that for the sake of saving lives trump
must be removed in november
this is an opportunity that is not the
left
becoming destructive and stooping to the
level of the right
in a substantive way this is optics and
i think
it's an opportunity to hit trump with it
period and it should be done it's no
major thing but it's a dig
and it could trigger trump again uh to
react in an unhinged way
doubling the damage now you might
remember trump also likes to call
coronavirus
the plague the term trump plague
is interesting to me because it
encompasses not just the virus being the
trump plague
but this administration being a plague
and beyond that
trump failing on the trump virus caused
the trump recession
he must be voted out before we have a
trump war there is a cohesive nature to
it that i don't think should be ignored
now by the way instead of starting a war
with another country trump is starting a
conflict
domestically between federal and local
law enforcement with these deployments
of paramilitaries to cities like
portland oregon i talked to you earlier
in the show
about donald trump's announcement
yesterday that he's going to be
deploying them to chicago
this is another version of starting an
armed conflict but this one is within
our borders instead of beyond them
which is often a tool that presidents
look to use as they are approaching a
possible re-election so bottom line
political name calling is indeed
childish you are not wrong
but when it comes to this and this kind
of final sprint to try to remove donald
trump
democrats playing the games trump plays
when they don't lead to death and
destruction
i'm okay with but if we don't vote it's
all
bs it's just it's just wasted time we
have to vote
in november earlier if you have absentee
ballot access
if you have early voting access if we
don't this is all a waste of time
i hate wasting my time i like making
things happen i'm a pragmatist sometimes
people in the audience get mad at me
they say
you're being too pragmatic well listen
with all of this stuff
what matters is removing trump in
november and oh and by the way
maga flew also a reasonable alternative
for me to the trump virus
i'm really fine with whatever as long as
it points
to helping us remove this guy as soon as
possible
which is about three months and a week
from now
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes
and you get all of the important core
ideas and information from that book
it's perfect if you don't have enough
time to do all the reading you want to
do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing i
recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video